[Music]
good morning it is midday here in the
Seychelles 8 a.m. in the UK and we are
broadcasting live to you from the Indian
Ocean at a depth of around 816 feet
which is 250 meters it is the deepest we
have been yet on deep ocean live and if
the communications hold and the currents
are favourable we could possibly go of
the bit deeper I can tell you I
broadcast from some pretty remote and
amazing places in my time but none quite
so remote or amazing as this let me just
show you the picture here and it's quite
unnerving in some ways it's like we've
descended into it all together sort of
alien world which of course we have it's
like a moonscape but the bottom of the
sea it this step there's barely a
glimmer of sunlight what you're seeing
are the lights of the submersible the
technical name for where we are as the
rarer photic zone and if you saw our
programme yesterday with anna well this
is a now about a hundred metres deeper
and what's so exciting about this is
that we are probably the first down here
it's largely unexplored unmapped an
unsurveyed and so in some ways it is a
privilege to be here the job today the
task today is to establish the impact of
man on the ocean deep down here and on
the surface anna is today on the surface
on the beat of our Babur itself
I am indeed mark and while you're
searching down below I'm here on the
equally remote and equally are the
worldly algebra at all it is a pristine
paradise but one that's having to deal
with a tide of plastic it is washing up
here from Asia and Africa and has
nowhere to go so a team of British
researchers and local Seychellois are
cleaning it up one flip-flop at a time
but for some of the animals it is too
late our waste is killing them
and I'm on the deck of the mothership of
the nekton mission the ocean Zephyr mark
is directly below us Anna on the
delightful beach over there on an
algebra at all I'm be joined by
Professor Louise Allcock who is one of
the scientists on board and also
professional zoology at the national
university of ireland
in galway she has studied the deep and
she finds plastic down there we'll be
discussing that and more on deep ocean
life mark yes we are on something of a
hunt today even down here I should to
say the species down here evolved over
millions of years long before we walked
on earth yet the threats facing them now
are unprecedented but here even in these
pristine seas is there a threat from
plastic pollution coral bleaching and
climate change well that's what we hope
to find out in the next hour we want to
reveal just a little bit maybe about
what's really happening in the deep and
if we start with one thought in mind it
must be this that a recent study by
Newcastle University scientists
suggested there is more than three
hundred and ninety-three million tons of
plastic in our oceans but only two
hundred and forty six thousand tons is
on the surface that means that 99% our
99.9 percent is suspended in the water
around us it's lying in the bottom it'll
buried in the seabed and it's a quite a
frightening a frightening thought Randy
and I mean how much different is this
from where you were yesterday hundred
meters
further out well we've gone a lot deeper
today and the landscape has changed
quite a bit so instead of seeing that
vertical wall we're seeing more of a
slope of hard bedrock and these broken
boulders that were clinging to right now
yeah and we're having to cling on
because that the slope is so sharp here
and what about being down here you know
it's very deep as I say it's 250 meters
the pressure is what something like you
know 325 times what we're seeing on the
surface down here yeah and the it's 25
times that's 360 I'm working it out 367
psi and the temperature down here is 12
degrees Celsius where I was at the top
on that ship where I was yesterday it
was you know 34 degrees what kind of
depth in this submersible we're in I'm
not getting worried what kind of depth
in this withstand well even though it's
designed for 300 meters they pressure
test it to 25% beyond that and designed
for even deeper so like we say I mean we
can go to any job sometimes yeah
but the pressure on us now I mean if we
tried to it's it's so much that we
couldn't open the hatch if we wanted to
in fact I could undock it and there's no
way you could open that hatch there's so
much force holding it
right and I said at the beginning we may
try and get deeper in this submersible
only now how much deeper could we go we
could go down to 300 meters yeah
and I should give you I'm just looking
down actually in it's very very tough no
I really want to go any further quick
reminder you can get involved on social
media using the hashtag deep ocean live
we're on sky near Sky Atlantic we're
also being streamed on the Sky News app
on our Twitter feed and on YouTube and
tomorrow we're going to have a
question-and-answer with students which
will be extraordinary so get your
questions in if you want to the hashtag
deep ocean live do that for us
now let's talk to Thomas Moore on the
ship and Thomas you said it would be
dark you said it would be different and
it is I mean this is the real photic
zone wearing is it your are you well
into the twilight zone whether it's an
actual rera photic zone that's the kind
of research the scientists onboard the
nekton ship are trying to do certainly
they found evidence of this rare footage
zone when they were last doing their
work in Bermuda it is a distinct zone
they found and that's the kind of work
they'll be doing here it is something
that nobody has seen before down here
now Deborah you are the first to be
exploring these deaths mark and I envy
you hugely and is an otherworldly an
alien world that you're seeing there and
the longer you spend down there I'm sure
the more life you will see clearly in
fact you can just see under the rock
there Louise what's that that's probably
a grouper isn't it
probably it's hard to see it's gone
already
there is a lot down there mark as Louise
saying that you just need time it will
come out is probably dazzled by the
light setting the brightest lights
creatures down there will have ever seen
probably and slowly they will emerge out
of the shadows and you will see more and
more perhaps even a shark as Ana saw
yesterday yeah I mean we've we've seen
sea urchins we've seen sea cucumbers as
a there's a few a red really what's the
cool and but they said there's a lot
down here all right but I don't know if
I could ask Lucy you know the point of
this program is to talk about plastic
and it's the minuscule pieces of plastic
sort of micro plastic that that reaches
this depth which is almost invisible I
mean we can see a kind of marine snow
down here I mean are them micro plastic
in that is their micro plastic in that
sort of marine snow this plastic on the
surface then it's likely that it's going
to get broken up and it degrades and
goes into small fibers and small pieces
and the problem with these pieces is
that is that
so fine all the filter feeders down
there like the corals and the sponges
they will just draw that into them with
the water so without taking cores or
without bringing some of these animals
up and and actually looking under the
microscope in detail for the micro
plastic I can't answer that question but
there's a very high likelihood that
there's microfiber micro plastics down
there
yeah I'm sorry Louisa it's your voice
isn't it it's not Lucy it's Louisa
thanks very much for being there I mean
and I read a report recently which said
that we face a future with more plastic
in the ocean than fish by 2050 is it
really that worrying getting into the
ocean because there isn't really a way
to get it out at the ocean there's been
attempts with the ocean cleanup but the
micro plastics are there and we're not
going to be able to remove them so you
know we have to stop putting them in
that's the only way to do it and so we
have to change our practices and
government policies and things can play
a role in this but we have to stop
putting plastic in the ocean
[Music]
we seem to have lost contact with mark
at the moment Louise I'll keep going now
you've been looking at plastics in the
deep in the area that you research off
the coast of Ireland tell me what you
find down there we don't specifically
study micro plastics or plant or
plastics but we can't help but see them
so I'm working in deep Canyon systems
you have to imagine the Grand Canyon but
underwater and off the Atlantic margin
and Ireland do you see that and and we
are just home running a deepwater ROV in
there and we find that everywhere we go
we find fishing Road particularly long
lines we find plastic bags we find old
Hessian sacks and we find fauna tangled
in these as well particularly the
monofilament fishing line you find crabs
and things caught in it and unable to
release themselves and they're just
gonna starve I mean it's horrid and do
you know where that plastic is coming
from
well the fishing lines obviously that
any any fishing gear is coming this
coming from fishing activities plastic
bags are probably just coming from land
even possibly people think they've
disposed of them sensibly and they've
gone to landfill sites but wind still
sweeps across landfill sites as it takes
rubbish away and people's bins you see
them in the street they've been knocked
over on collection day rubbish sweeps
away because I live right off the coast
in Galway
so things go off the land into the sea
and they end up in the deep and that
sinks then and it rolls down the
continental shelf into the deep where
you're working
that's right everything's always going
to go downward so the deep sea is where
it's at and we can't get it out of there
once it's there so we have to stop
putting it in do we thank you very much
so Anna
well sure can you see any plastic you
there is absolutely no escaping it I
have to say Thomas the boat behind you
almost feel like giving you away but we
are on Aldabra atoll it is pristine it
has been almost totally protected for
nearly 40 years it is the most
extraordinary place if you look at the
world of the submersibles as being alien
here it feels prehistoric there are
reptiles roaming there are birds in the
sky that looked like they should be
pterosaurs I have never been anywhere
like this the scale of this is enormous
- best scene in fact from the air we
sent a drone up earlier to show you some
of the extraordinary images of Aldabra
atoll it is 21 miles long that's almost
the same as from Dover to Calais
the lagoon itself which is shallow a
nesting site for the black tip reef
sharks and for the lemon sharks as well
who bring up their young there not to
mention the critically endangered
hawksbill turtles who also go in there
green turtles out here the hawksbills go
in there it is the most extraordinary
place to be
also here of course the importance of
coral is everywhere to be seen it is
made of coral if the coral starts to die
eventually this place will die it will
weather let's walk you over shall we -
what is an ancient coral wall and
joining me here now is dr. Lindsey
Turnbull who is on the board of the
Seychelle Islands foundation who looks
after this extraordinary place but here
we have complete corals don't we it's
amazing yeah so this is probably about
125,000 years old and that's the last
time that this at all emerged so because
of changes in sea level they can
torille can suddenly find itself lifted
up above and then of course it just dies
so this is fossilized coral and there's
a fabulous mushroom coral the entire
thing fossilized into the wall there
sometimes you can even see enormous
fossilized giant clams just part of
these walls spectacular but not fun to
climb on on or walk on it's part of the
brutality of this place that you don't
want to start climbing up there and that
was the interesting thing we spent the
night here trying to find somewhere for
a tent for example was really
interesting wasn't it because because of
the spike enos of the coral I described
it as a prehistoric world it is so
extraordinary the animals that are here
it must be a privilege for you to be
part of this oh and absolutely I think
for anyone who's ever had their luck or
privilege of setting foot on this place
they all feel that magic within minutes
of arrival it completely captures you at
an emotional level and you feel that you
must do whatever you can to try to be
part of the of the saving of this place
of keeping it the way it is which of
course the Seychelles government have
paid played the most important role in
that in giving it this incredible level
of protection the only problem is of
course is this here it is the plastic
we're talking about and I know this is
not as bad as some of the beaches in the
South but describe the sorts of things
you find here well the items are just
the state of it well either okay well I
mean we are thousands of miles from any
major population center so when I stand
and look at this I just asked myself
where does it come from this looks like
a beach where people come and regularly
have massive parties and leave their
stuff behind but that's not what's
happened this stuff has come from all
over the world this is our global
rubbish and unfortunately for algebra it
is exposed to an enormous current that
flows south of the Equator and just
brings all this stuff to here well we
are on one of the four islands that make
up algebra at all you are not allowed
here unless you are a ranger or invited
by organisations like you and I know
you've been organizing a clean up the
Aldabra cleanup project with Oxford
University and a national competition to
get CLO our people involved as well
they're here
what we're going to try to do is see if
our volunteers can clean up this beach
during our program today during deep
ocean life it's hard hot work okay
off you go right we'll see their
progress throughout this morning also
evidence that the giant tortoises here a
hundred and fifty thousand them are
eating flip flops we've seen it in the
excrement we'll show you an example a
little bit later mark back down to you
in the depths
yeah well and I'm very lost
communications there briefly but we're
now trying to re-establish them and I
hope you can see me and we're moving now
to get closer to one of the remote
operated cameras and to the receiver
it's all done by like we're sending
basically LED lights this is extremely
difficult what we're trying to do here
the connection the optical connection no
wires involved whatsoever very difficult
to keep the receiver and the transmitter
together and that's what happens
sometimes that's why we're losing mark
down in the deep but I'm still here with
Eloise Allcock Louisa you were telling
me earlier that one of your students has
looked at coral and and how they're
eating microplastic we're on a coral
atoll and as you said there's every
likelihood that there is microplastic
tiny fragments of everyday items in the
water here that's not great for the
coral it's not great for the coral
because the coral needs to take in
carbon as a as a food source and if it's
taking
think obviously it can't digest that we
don't know how detrimental it is
actually to corals at this moment but we
do know that the oceans suffer from
various stressors and we need to reduce
those stresses as much as possible and
obviously something effectively being
fed plastic unknowingly is a stressor so
so we need to try to stop that yes of
course many people may not realize that
coral is actually a living animal
there's not a plant is a living animal
it is in effect a living carnivorous
Rock isn't it that's right I mean
there's many animals in the seed that
actually lived like plants they grow
have they have a bush like structure and
they just look like plants but they are
all animals they're quite simple animals
but they are filter feeding away they're
not photosynthesizing in in the shallow
waters stony corals have symbiotic algae
then these algae do free to synthesize
and that's how they get their carbon but
once we get into deep water the corals
are filter feeding and they're getting
their resources from the water
and of course one of the things that
really impact in coral now is the
warming sees what damage does that do to
the reefs around a places like Aldabra
todate how the Opera hasn't suffered
very much and that's partly because of
where it is because there are so few
people here just those people on the
scientific station it doesn't have other
stresses there's not much pollution in
the water we've got the plastic but we
haven't got the sunscreens the waste the
sediment from on land activities and so
because the other stresses are less the
warming is having a lesser effect not
quite such a drastic effect but it will
come because global temperatures are
rising all the time so that is coming to
Aldabra so it seems to be more resistant
than coral elsewhere because we've seen
these mass bleaching events over the
last few decades with a terrible impact
on on coral reefs yeah that's right and
I mean the waters are very warm here
they're 30 degrees so that you know
there is a real risk of coral bleaching
here but it's not a tourist spot it
doesn't have people there isn't waste
going into the sea there isn't pollution
there's chemical waste from industry
going into the sea all these are
stressors on coral and so they make the
coral react more strongly to to the
and coral bleaching that's when the the
coral it it turns a ghostly why just
explain what's going on what that what
impact that has on on the reefs and the
broader ecosystem so so normal stony
corals have had symbiotic algae living
with them and these argue do the
photosynthesis and that is providing the
sugars that's the energy of the reef
it's just like plants growing on land
then the the base of the food chain and
so when the corals bleach what they
actually do is because they're under
stress they expel the symbiotic algae
and once there's algae are gone they
come there's no photosynthesis and
there's no base of the food chain if
there's no base of the food chain
there's nothing and so the coral the
reef dies completely so this has an
impact on on the fish that have such an
intimate relationship with that
environment absolutely it impacts
everything so all this is really
something that that scientists are here
to mainly to study looking at every
depth from the shallows down to the deep
and of course this is the first time
that scientists with their submersibles
with their drop cameras to have really
been able to look at what is going on
very deep far beyond the reach of scuba
divers now perhaps we were able to
re-establish links with that with Mark
unfortunately with whole depth mark is
still not in range of the blue comb
device so let's go back to Anna on
algebra you very much indeed having seen
how close that plate that sits above the
submersibles has to come yesterday when
I was down there you realize this is
just the most extraordinary daft
technology that anybody is trying I have
to say it's it's deep deep in the ocean
wafting in the currents trying to get a
communication with a submersible you
know it's extraordinary anyway so here
also this I have to say is the first
live television brought us that anybody
has done here where we are on algebra at
all the things they're finding already
in this plastic some is children's shoes
absolutely loads of them as you can see
plastic bottles we know about the
problem of plastic bottles why there are
so many flip-flops that's been
extraordinary they've cleared the south
island they found 50,000 flip-flops
50,000 flip-flops down there dr. Lindsey
Turnbull you at the
person that have driven this hour
Deborah clean that project your
volunteers are working hard why was it
so important to do you think well I
think of you as we said before if you
have the privilege to come here and it
captures your heart then you really
cannot when you see this it breaks your
heart right this should not be here it's
an absolute travesty and I really wanted
to be part of the solution although it
was at the station as Ireland's
foundation who really recognized this
problem and knew that they needed to
organize a massive effort to get it
cleaned up we thought it'd be really
great to do a a collaborative project
because it's a global problem it's not
the people of the Seychelles who have
put this rubbish here this is not where
it's come from
its global rubbish you know that
toothpaste toothbrush on the beach there
could be my toothbrush actually and I
think we do need to be part of the
solution yes okay well what's
interesting here is if we swing right
round and I'm trying to not let our
cameraman fall in here there we go that
is a turtle nesting size and I have to
say that last night we saw a turtle
struggling to lay its eggs I'm not sure
there is a single egg left this is a
dog-eat-dog world of predator and prey
not least more so than down in the deep
ocean where you are mark
you can hear me now because we're what
we're doing we're moving from the
position we were because we got rid out
of alignment with the receiver that
we're sending the signal and we're
having this extraordinary journey over
this moonscape down here that we're
still at 815 feet so just under two
hundred and fifty meters and we are
seeing the most extraordinary some coral
all sorts of reef fish down here and it
is really something else and they're
just deeply there you can see in the
distance through that the other
submarine of just putting your lights on
there and we're just trying to get
closer to that submarine so we can be
realigned with it and and I think we can
check with who can we check with Ben you
were telling me with Thomas up on the
phone the phone yeah but Randy I mean
what just watch explain what are we
trying to do here right now we're just
trying to get keep our comms up and
we're watching the Kensington they're
doing a science survey so have the other
sub but yeah so they have these stereo
cameras and I'm just trying to kind of
avoid the rocks here and
come up behind them let me check in with
the surface real quick okay topside
topside Omega comms check
[Music]
so I don't even know where the rack
comes with the surface are working we
are though I can see now at yeah about
two fifty to sixty meters down so you
can understand some of the problems that
we're having so maneuvering the
submersible and at the same time staying
in line would be led receiver is the
issue that we're having at the moment
but Tom times what I say I mean we're
talking about the impact as they move
further along the reef but Louise
Aldabra is so far from anywhere and yet
it gets so much plastic that clearly
isn't originating here there are just
not enough people so we're not still
coming from it's coming from elsewhere
around the Indian Ocean so we have
massive global currents but they're
driven by actually by Antarctic ice as
that freezes
the water underneath it slightly more
salty as the freshwater is pulled out
with that salty water sinks in jives
Antarctic bottom water out across the
ocean floor and at the same time we've
got winds in the north blowing in this
sets up so global current system same
have you got the earth spinning and
that's having an effect and so we have
fairly consistent strong currents
everybody at home will have heard about
the Gulf Stream that's one of those
currents and we've similarly got
currents in the Indian Ocean and they're
bringing rubbish here from much more
densely populated place places and the
Seychelles is just unlucky it's bang in
the middle of the ocean and it's getting
the waste from us so just a victim of
geography yes basically and we do hear
about these gyres these swirling
currents that trap plastic and
particularly in the Pacific Ocean and
indeed in the Atlantic - and that's
where the plastic can can remain for
many decades yes it can and there's been
efforts to go out and play this up but
it's not easy to clear up because you've
seen us running unused on that's off the
back of the ship these are the Nets the
very fine mesh Nets they used to collect
this surface layer of living organisms
but you collect much else - I'm sure we
do but we're primarily there for the
organisms we've only collected a little
bit of rubbish in those Nets but the
trouble is if you try to clean the
plastic up from those surface waters you
clean the new stone off as well
so these small planktonic floating
animals that don't really have control
over their own destiny they're floating
where the currents go they're getting
cleaned up with the plastic and quite a
lot of scientists have never worried
about about this with with plastic
cleanup so that's the unintended
consequence that you might be hoovering
up as well as the plastic you might be
hoovering up the eggs the larvae all
those other things that are so important
to life in the oceans exactly and it's a
very large complex food web and if we
are interfering with it then we it's
very difficult to predict what the
effects of that would be so if you can't
clean up the oceans what do you do don't
put it in there in the first place
we need policy changes from governments
we really need governments to go onboard
and we need all the people to get on
board to put pressure on governments to
do to make some action governments can
change all sorts of things a small piece
of legislation could for example ban
plastic fit flip-flops there are other
ways of making shoes but there are two
billion people who live around the
Indian Ocean in some of the world's
poorest countries - they don't have
proper waste management so what do you
do in those circumstances well I think
you made a lovely suggestion earlier
Thomas when we were talking off-camera
when we talked about dead swaps
for Ocean action and I think you know
that that is a lovely idea where rich
and nations can can contribute and in
return we we get some action on some of
these issues that we need and what I was
saying there was that the Seychelles has
swapped some of its dead for money that
it needs to protect the marine
environment and it has some of the best
protected seas on the planet so perhaps
the same idea could be followed through
as you say with with waste management to
give these poorer nations the money to
start up recycling schemes to collect
their ways and just stop that plastic
flowing out to sea yeah absolutely and
the foreign nations will benefit from
this as well we need cleaner oceans
everywhere cleaner seas it benefits
tourism a healthier ocean allow
sustainable fishing better so it is
actually to everybody's benefit that we
have clean healthy oceans Louise thank
you very much
so and let's return to you because you
are really seeing the the front line of
the plastic pollution here in in the
Indian Ocean and as you say so many
flips I was on the island yesterday and
I even saw the cutouts used to make
flip-flops it is quite incredible the
site that I've never seen yes and in
fact I've seen one of those as well
Thomas I've got a couple of the people
here who've been working hard to try and
clean at least this Beach they've been
down in the south as well Kelsey well
let's start with you what's the bag that
you're collecting there I've got sand
shoes like why do you try to break them
into a different thing we're trying to
see how we can what is accumulating on
the beaches what are the different
categories of things so that for SIF to
know afterwards where these different
things are coming from and what type of
things are ending up on the beach
depending on the terrain that there is
on the island as well and I suppose some
things like fishing boys for example
might be reusable for this fisherman
back in Marky and other places in the
Seychelles but you've been down in the
south I mean you told us that this is
nothing compared with what you saw down
there
yeah really in the south as like massive
barrels sometimes we discover as well as
like you get a little protruding items
that you think you can just pull out and
then all of a sudden if I stop digging
really really deep to try and get a
massive pad or there's like a fad is a
fish an aggregation device and it's used
to try and attract fish and then the
fishermen come along and take all of the
fish that they found there yes
and sometimes I think they drift of
course and they end up on the shores and
those are really difficult because
they're um they're a mix of boys with
nets and bamboos so when they get
entangled in either the cast or on the
beach itself it's very difficult to try
and maneuver it out and pull it out
especially the ropes and if you've got a
combination of sand like on the cast it
can be quite dangerous because we're
like basically trying to hang over like
almost like a cliff and you've got your
knife and you try to pull the rope so
yeah it can be quite a ski but further
south as well they say that still there
is illegal drift net fishing as well
which is really sad to see because it's
so indiscriminate and takes all the
species that we've been seeing in the
ocean behind us and here too this is an
important thing isn't it
that this is a turtle nesting Beach and
the turtles have to wade their way
through the plastic that we're seeing
here and sometimes they Ribery it so you
might be cleaning this beach now but it
will re-emerge which is really difficult
you have to almost start again yeah in
the South actually we were we did
different beaches on different days and
there was one beach we finished but
clearly we were very very happy with
them or we are collected and then like
five days later we came back and it was
almost like it was so discouraging but I
agree we've removed some but we know
that there's layers and layers and
layers of it so it's really hard to know
how deep to go and how much to dig out
and yeah but you know everyday love
counts like yes and we were privileged
enough to see a a female turtle battling
yesterday a green turtle battling to try
and make one of these holes where they
lay their nests it's exhausting work for
them it was grunting as it tried to do
and in fact the one we saw tried three
different holes and Lindsey I know it
was you that worked me up to come and
see this I say work up it's almost
impossible to sleep when robber crabs
are trying to get into your into your
tent and the work that the Turtles do to
get up here to fight their way through
and we think that the turtle we saw
laying last night her eggs have all gone
should we see if we can get towards
those as we as we go yeah sure I mean
there are were as we saw there was an
army of robber crabs literally circling
around her just waiting for the
opportunity to get in and take those
eggs this morning I've watched one of
our wonderful endemic species on our
Dabra which is the flightless rail also
wandering around with hatchlings in its
mouth they look dead so presumably they
were ones that emerged
nest too far back on the beach and they
just couldn't make it if they emerge in
daylight they risk obviously just being
dehydrated and dried up in the Sun so
everything is out to get those poor
things it's a real battle against the
odds we'll walk towards Craig and
towards Stefanie as well and see if we
can see the actual well live nearly all
gone then the Flies are all buzzing
around them aren't they
this is the nest that eventually our
turtle tried to lay her eggs I say our
turtle we watched her for about an hour
and a half and if you go right down
there if you can see all the Flies look
at those eggs they've already gone and I
think we don't know if she was just too
exhausted to cover them too exhausted to
cover her hatchlings so they stay in
there and the robber crabs would have
gone in and sucks out all the goodness
and that this one thing that's really
struck me about both the marine
environment and being underwater things
like black tip reef sharks that are
nocturnal that the fact that the reef
allows hiding places for all the smaller
fish the predator and prey aspect of the
natural world is truly shocking when you
say it like this I think the problem is
in a lot of the environments that we're
used to encountering predators have
often been eliminated or are much lower
density that may would be in an intact
place like this and that is one of the
things that you've really noticed is
that the number of apex predators but
that's actually a sign of a really
healthy ecosystem the system needs
predators and certainly on coral reefs
that's been shown that coral reefs with
healthy shark populations are generally
much healthier so yes well in fact
Thomas More was able to film near where
the ranger station is actually honest on
just on the other part of the coral
atoll I was able to film the turtles
nesting overnight as well as I said it's
such hard work for them and what is
really distressing is when you see
animals that have been caught in marine
bits and bobs and in fact I know that
Seychelles Islands Foundation has filmed
one a loggerhead turtle they passed by
here they're not really
they didn't base themselves here but
they're on migration through here and in
fact we have lots of incredible animals
that just come by our dabber and it's
important staging pace for them there
are humpback whales that comes
through here which you can see breaching
of the settlement beach whale sharks
there's a whole additional fauna that is
just migratory here and the pictures
were of the loggerhead wrapped around in
fishing gear and in fact some of this
sort of stuff is the probably part of
this fish aggregation devices it's
really common to use this technique for
tuna fishing so if you're thinking about
your tuna sandwich later today there is
a very good chance that it will be a
fish aggregation device that has been
used but fishing is really important to
the Seychelles economy so the question
is should it be better regulated rather
than banned are there ways that these
fish aggregation devices could be used
better better for species so that
doesn't get cut off and left to just
float in and this is part of the stuff
that the turtles that you see I caught
him but green turtles here are a success
story aren't they tell us why there are
an enormous success story they were
hunted here in the in the old days where
this island was exploited but since that
time they've been very heavily protected
since the late sixties early seventies
and we've really watched their
populations booming and that's a
fantastic thing to see what we don't
want to see is that going into reverse
or into decline and yeah there's nothing
to worry about because this is just a
piece of natural debris but actually
this is part of a fish aggregation
device these poles float on the surface
and then there are great sheets of net
that hang down and it's those nets that
really cause the problem but even these
large obstructions if you're a turtle
you're already exhausted you're trying
to dig a massive hole they don't really
want to be encountering too many of
these and although there aren't too many
on this particular Beach there are
places where the nesting grounds are
literally littered with okay Lindsey for
the moment thanks very much indeed giant
tortoises giant tortoises so many that's
what they they're 150,000 that compares
with the population in the Seychelles of
93 or round 93 thousand over on the ship
let's go back shall we to Thomas More
and thank you very much indeed an
absolutely fascinating discussion you've
been having there about a tuna and of
course tuna are very closely related to
what's happening on on coral reefs a
very intimate connection look juvenile
tuna would spend time there so what
happens on the reefs with bleaching and
climate change and so on that will
affect the availability of tuna in the
future so that's that's your lunch
potentially that could be affected but
we're joined in London by David de
Rothschild David I hope you can you can
join us now your family has a very
intimate connection with Aldabra over
over many years
tell us more yeah just yeah well good
morning and the very luxurious round
about here and Austin not sitting in the
bottom of the summary which I would like
to be doing with you guys in the
submersible one of my great uncle's
Walter was very connected to algebra he
was a zoologist who was very keen on
protecting those breeding centuries that
you talk about back in the turn of the
last century in 1902 1908 he actually
rented the island to try and stop
poachers and to protect the species he
was known for his quite outlandish
behavior when it came to using zebras
and and giant tortoises to ride on but
he brought a lot of awareness and
education and kind of formed and helped
to inform you know the public about
these far-flung places that we didn't
have the technology we have today to
connect us so this was bringing
education and information to the world
about different species and the
importance of protecting them he was as
I said a very early zoologist and very
keen on on protecting these fragile
ecosystems
but David there are so many examples of
conservation success on the island not
least the green turtles which have have
bounced back and now one of the most
important nesting sites for for green
sea turtles in the whole of the Indian
Ocean and indeed the giant tortoise many
people may not even realize that there
are giant tortoises away from the
Galapagos and they were nearly hunted to
extinction and yet now as Anna said
there are more tortoises than there are
people in the Seychelles yeah I mean
there are these huge success stories and
I think that's one of the things that we
we have to start recognizing that for
all the problems that we're hearing this
morning and we see on a daily basis and
the problems we have you know around
this in sort of a degrading environment
nature is entirely resilient it has this
capacity to regenerate it's been around
for four-and-a-half billion years
you know and we live on this incredible
planet that can sustain itself without
us and here we are putting these human
finger prints all throughout these
fragile ecosystems so I think it's a bit
of self-reflection to stop look listen
learn from nature and then really look
at what we can do to support rather than
hinder this incredible planet Earth you
really need to give nature time to
recover and how important do you think
it is that the the Seychelles government
has brought in this enormous marine
protected area around Aldabra where
there is no commercial fishing allowed I
mean it's vital these are the these are
the vital marine protected areas that
are sort of Hope spots in the ocean we
need to give nature a chance to to
recover we can't keep on just you know
dipping into this natural bank
we've gone well we're sort of overdrawn
as it were and so to create leadership
the Seychelles is creating leadership we
need to increase the marine protected
areas you know we are on planet ocean
you are in planet ocean you can get
sense of the justice scale and the
and the importance of that ecosystem so
if we're not taking a leadership role in
creating hope spots for the ocean then
what we're seeing is dead spots in the
ocean we see overfishing exploitation
and that then is a knock-on effect
because you know we often point fingers
at the fisherman and we blame the
fisherman but we're a global economy
where global consumers it still blows my
mind to think that we can pull wild fish
from the ocean and that can sustain us
on this planet with the number of people
who are reliant on that as a protein but
there are livelihoods attached to this
we can't just point fingers at the
fishermen we have to create system
change from how we eat in the
restaurants all the way down to the
ocean and how we protect this those you
know those breeding grounds those
sanctuaries pull the fish to recover so
this is an integrated system system
thinking and we really have to lead by
example which is what the Seychelles is
doing David owns the Seychelles are
rightly proud of the paradise they have
here on Aldabra but there's very little
that people here can do to resist the
wave of a plastic pollution of warm
water in a since this is a global issue
we all have a stake in the future of
algebra we can all make those choices as
you're saying to help places like
algebra survive well into the future
[Music]
yeah I mean this is a global issue you
know this is something that we are all
you know connected to we are on planet
earth and you know and we're on this
spaceship that is you know spinning
around in the middle of nowhere
as far as we can tell there's no other
planet you know that can sustain us like
this planet can so we have to look after
our home we're all connected we're all
part of this system and and I think
ultimately that is the biggest thing
that we have to focus on is the
solutions here today you know for all
the problems that we face the solutions
we have available to us exist you know I
really hope that as we start to get the
message out about this plastic issue
that we can step up the actual banning
of some of these single-use plastics
that you're seeing here across the
islands I mean this is not something
that requires anything more than just
some visions and leadership you know we
can stop this today we don't need to be
you know making these long-term we think
we're gonna try and reduce stuff by you
know 2030 or 2040 why don't we do this
today take the leadership get the
leaders around the table we just had the
UN environment meeting in Nairobi for
the environment ministers we had some
you know some interesting conversations
but I would say we need to go further
this is something that we're all
involved in we can all be part of the
solution and we need to step up our game
otherwise we are going to see species
disappearing from the face of this
planet
purely because of our plastic dependency
the fact that we're throwing away
thousands of tons of plastic every year
300 million tons of plastic that's
almost equivalent to the weight of all
the population on this planet so we need
to step up our game it's a moral
responsibility it's an obligation that
all of us should have and and I think
that's the only way we can keep moving
forward David thank you very much for
joining us from London but back here on
or Debra is Anna some of the back of the
envelope calculations that have been
done
by the volunteers there is that there
are 1000 tons of plastic on the island
so they're making a small dent and of
course every tide brings in more plastic
ana yes indeed and one animal that has
been eating that plastic is right in
front of us there a giant Aldabra
tortoise
land tortoises like this have been
around for 200 million years and only in
two places in the world are they now
endemic and that is the Galapagos
Islands and here on Aldabra atoll
150,000 of them this story is remarkable
they were the chosen food of sailors
they can go for months without food and
water they would bundle them into their
ships put them down in the ship's hold
leave them there and then eat them when
they needed to
here on Aldabra they were almost wiped
out by 1900 and certainly Charles Darwin
is amongst those people who've tried to
save the Aldabra giant tortoise it's an
extraordinary thing to see them here in
the wild it is of course just after noon
here the tortoises need to get out of
the Sun they need to because they could
cook to death quite literally and dr.
Lindsey Turnbull is here with me now it
is so amazing to live amongst them one
slip right by my tent last night and
when they fall asleep it's as if they've
expired they can't go on any further yes
they remind you of a sort of clockwork
toy that only has so much life in it and
eventually at the end of the day the
clockwork just runs down and they just
stop wherever they happen to be and
you'll find them there in the morning
will now wake up again and if we look
down here we've got another endemic
species a mother and her young this is
the Aldabra flightless rail if you think
of the dodo the famous dodo it's
probably just about hidden now in there
they are amazing they're very friendly
they're not used to people it just shows
wildlife not used to people there's the
young chick that's been eating the
turtle hatchlings today we've seen them
running off with them off the beach and
that is extraordinary to see because
there's no other flightless bird left in
the western Indian Ocean that's right
and flightless birds are one of those
great casualties of humans arriving on
Islands this is why this is such an
extraordinary place it's an island lots
of things can't
and in particular and mammalian
predators can't get here naturally and
that allows all kinds of mad experiments
and evolution to take place including
flightless birds
unfortunately when humans arrive as you
were just describing they came here to
harvest the tortoises and to harvest the
Turtles but what they brought with them
were rats or cats or pigs were goats and
those things that actually devastating
to Ireland wildlife and that's one of
the big things that SIF is always trying
to do is to eradicate any invasive
species that have got here our Opera is
not quite pristine because we still have
rats and cats on some islands although
not on Malabar and yeah so it's it's
good to see this guy he's so tame like
you say is one of the real great
characters of this island getting back
to the giant tortoises are there too
many of them because 150,000 we can see
if we look at some of the trees as well
they eat absolutely everything they can
a little tree here
no lower branches because they literally
live off vegetation don't they they need
everything they can and actually in the
dry season they can starve to death
can't they yes absolutely and I don't
know if your camera's able to pan around
but you can see some shells behind right
that's exactly what's happened to them
they simply have expired perhaps they've
overheated perhaps they weren't able to
find enough food and we don't they're
not predator limited so you have to you
have to ask yourself when you ask other
too many of something what limits their
population size and basically animals
are limited by one or two things they're
either limited by food or they're
limited by predators these things don't
really have a lot of predators as adults
but they are limited by the number of
food the amount of food but that doesn't
mean there's too many of them and you
know as long as they are replacing
themselves then the population is stable
and this population is stable yes
and in fact we've got some flip-flop in
some excrement I think over there which
will get them in I just want to show you
before we go there this is the tortoise
skull quite small
these massive leg bones as well that
hold them up and you can see beyond this
carapace that line here the weight they
have to carry and the hip bone over
there as well as it sort of begins to
disintegrate it's amazing to see these
just lying around and if I you do see
some of them dead they see Turtles dead
as well some of the mothers that simply
can't get back to the water in time
lapse
exhausted they come overnight they sit
in the Sun and if they don't get back to
the water they will die same with these
guys as well if they don't get into the
shade and the midday Sun we saw them
under the trees there they literally
will cook inside they'll cook to death
terrible
they're so slow-moving as well that you
just don't know if they're gonna get
back into the Sun in time so show us
what we've got to hear them yes well
this is a tortoise poo and you know it's
a tortoise pee because it doesn't appear
to be able to digest things terribly
well so we can see whole dead leaves in
here and that's just the natural food of
the tortoise they will have a go at
pretty much anything and that's the
problem with this because if I turn it
over you can see that this tortoise has
been chomping away on one of those
flip-flops that our team has just been
cleaning up so the tortoises do go down
onto the beaches even though there
doesn't appear to be much there that
there they will have a go at anything
they will scavenge away at things and
they just don't understand that this is
not food and they will eat it and the
colours also attract them so we did some
experiments with coloured rice balls
actually to find out which colors they
particularly liked and red and yellow
colors were particularly attractive to
them but as you can see they seem pretty
clean on these green flip-flops as well
amazing to see an endemic species the
other one that's been catching my
attention I have to say apart from the
fruit bits which I know is a fruit bats
which is a national delicacy in the
Seychelles they're absolutely enormous
is the frigates that go over
they look like pterosaurs pterodactyls
we used to call them didn't we and it
gives this sense of this prehistoric
place which should be in a film or
something yeah exactly it really is a
lost world and the frigates actually
we're seeing them going overhead here
and heading out that way there's an
enormous frigate bird colony that's
again one of the secrets of the lagoon
so inside the lagoon is fringed with
mangroves and the frigate birds nest in
those mangroves and in fact the things
they're after which is the red footed
boobies nest right amongst them so
they're like very good neighbors sitting
together in their nest sites but as the
boobies come back with their fish from
the ocean the frigate birds are simply
patrolling waiting to attack them
waiting to get them to drop their cap so
they can seize it so it's a very strange
and uneasy relationship between those
two birds well from consuming whole
flip-flops
here the parts you can see let's go back
to Thomas and talk about microplastics
Deanna and that's something that all
this course has initialed every depth
but those microplastics often do settle
down on the seabed and that is the
workplace of Louise Louise you do
encounter quite a lot of plastic down
there of a very shape and form
presumably yeah we see a lot of a lot of
fishing gear a lot of bags not a person
sacks and sort of things that some of
the things that I've got tossed off the
side of ships but the real issue is the
is the micro plastics I think and we
can't see that but we have a deepwater
ROV remotely operated vehicle and we
have push pause on that so these are
just hollow tubes with a handle on them
and the robotic arm on the ROV is used
to push those deep into the sediment and
pull
I've set up a noun and we take those up
to the lab on the ship where we slice
those calls into centimeter depths and
then we preserve those very carefully
because we are covered in plastic
although clothes in places so we have to
wear cotton lab coats and try to do this
in a very clean conditions and we can
take them back to the lab and
microplastics in those and in fact
principal scientist on board oceans
therefore Lucy Woodall wrote one of the
sort of seminal papers on deep-sea micro
blast so this plastic is just getting
buried in the sediment at the bottom of
the sea that's right and there are there
are only people in the UK up in the SAMS
and Scotland we were looking back
I would say historic not quite that far
back but collections are from the ocean
that go back 40 years to look to see
whether when microplastics started first
started to appear so there's a lot of
research going on to see how long the
problem has been there and how extensive
the problem is actually in effect we're
putting a stamp human stamp on the
geological record of the current times
yeah I mean I you know if you humanity
survives another thousand years there
probably we haven't have a marker and
sediment layers of the plastic year and
just like we look for
now and of course we've seen this
enormous public reaction against
plastics they see what they're consuming
at home what they're coming home in
their shopping bags and then of course
what's ending up in places like algebra
or indeed inside the stomach's of whales
how would you kind of capture that
feeling of responsibility I suppose and
extend it to other effects of pristine
environments like Mount Everest like
climate change yeah I think the reaction
of the public of our plastics has been
fantastic and we need to be people have
fully embraced it and they've really
tried to cut down their plastic use and
they campaigned against plastic
wrappings and there's something but what
we meet now I think is for people to do
the same for carbon usage everybody to
look at themselves individually how can
I cut down my carbon usage and it could
be as simple as looking at your fruit in
the supermarket and buying local produce
front produce rather than something
that's flown in from you know halfway
across the globe but we can look at all
those issues you can look at you can
campaign to your government for grants
to for electric cars for better
insulation of your houses
we can component greatly on them Louise
there's some good advice something that
we can all do having watched what's been
happening here and our algebra we all
have a part to play in its future we can
all do something wherever we are in the
world and it back to you Thomas thanks
very much indeed let's just show you the
progress we've made on this speech
Thomas the bags are beginning to be
collected as you can see we'll get a
tally of that in just a moment let me
show you the sorts of things people are
getting plastic bottles the cutouts that
Thomas mentioned there of the flip-flops
lighters scrubbing brushes lots of
toothpastes even a lightbulb has found
its way here and some strange deodorant
I can't quite see where it is a lot of
this is organized too by the Seychelles
Islands foundation normally eleven to
twelve of them they've been built up by
the other bread cleanup group so there's
twenty five on the island we've added
four twenty nine people alone on this
island right now very quickly let's just
show you one of the camps they have it's
gonna go dark for a bit and here is
Jessica Mumma you're putting up a pot of
tea for the hard workers nearly finished
an amazing place to be you've obviously
got your mosquito nets up but a very
remote way of living yes it's it's quite
difficult for us to come here because
sometimes we can't get access to it but
when we do get the chance we come and do
some mentoring and it's why it's quite
nice and privilege for us to be here
well only 11 or 12 of you on the island
at any one time
you have to all get on I suppose don't
you and and with the robber crabs as I
found out lost it's not easy with the
robber crop and also that all toys
sometimes I will just come and just look
at you what are you doing here it's not
your place here but it's always nice to
be among them say well it's a very
memorable place to be and very memorable
for you to live here Jessica thanks very
much indeed we will say goodbye to that
right let's see shall we
how they've got on bags after bags after
bags right let's go and have a look okay
what have we got have you have you
managed to just about finish it do you
think yeah okay so what sorts of things
have we got in here
okay so plastic bottles full of plastic
bottles those are recyclable at home
obviously let's have a look at this one
this one is flip-flops we I don't if I
want to tip that out to you shall we tip
that out and show everybody what that
looks like I'll help you pick it up
after
those are our shoes we all wear them
they're cheap that's why they're so
popular and that's what's ended up Craig
I know that you're one of the say
shalwar volunteers aren't you you've got
a bell there that might be something
that could be reused absolutely yes so
one of the things that we're looking to
as part of the processing is to see how
we can get fishermen to use this thank
you so much all of you for your help
your hard work this morning we really
appreciate it
keep up the good work this is the most
extraordinary place to come thank you
very much indeed
so live from algebra at all just away
from the shores of the Indian Ocean and
our mothership the ocean Zephyr back to
you good morning from the Indian Ocean
and welcome we are broadcasting to you
live from around let's have a look
250 meters down in the Indian Ocean and
I suppose I should say welcome to The
Twilight Zone
we haven't broadcast this deep so far
we're now actually over 250 meters we've
been struggling if you've been following
the previous hour to get a link with
this receiver that comes down is
drop-down I can actually see the
receiver above us and firm that I can
see the outline shadow of the master
ship from which that the receiver was
dropped and from which these amazing
submersibles lifted into the sea and
then we descend and it doesn't say down
now to about 250 meters which is called
the rare a photic zone and down here
there is very little sunlight the light
that you can see let me show you what I
can see
that light that is another submersible
in front of me and these lights are the
lights of that submersible and yet that
is being lit by the light from this
submersible very little sunlight indeed
gets down here almost total darkness and
what's happening at the moment is these
two submersibles are undergoing
scientific experiments for the
scientists that we are working with on
the mothership the ocean Zephyr and it
really is an extraordinary place down
here it's like like a moonscape and the
corals are very different the creatures
are very different the corals are
flatter and to attract whatever light
there is and if you go much deeper past
sort of three four hundred meters then
the creatures people
we're losing mark their arm where he is
somewhere out there doesn't the ocean
look beautiful from here on the coral at
all of algebra mark wherever you are
stay safe I'm sure you will it's a an
extraordinary place to be down in those
submersibles and so deep as well down in
the Twilight Zone quite amazing to be
down there and seeing all those corals
that are straining for light that is not
the problem here they're not straining
for light what they're trying to do many
of the creatures here is battle the
plastic we've got the team here from the
Seychelle Islands Foundation and from
the Aldabra cleanup project who have
been cleaning this beach for us during
our coverage on deep ocean live and
talked us through some of our your
toothbrush there JC what are the sort of
things you found here I mean everything
in anything you can imagine that's ever
been made of plastic and these are just
some toothbrushes you might recognize
these brands anything this is a part of
a North Face flip-flop this is a the
packaging of a water bottle it's coming
from Malaysia this is
that's all the things that I find
interesting this is some orange juice
wrapping that's also come from that's
true from Indonesia and this is a king
chess piece one of our one of our other
volunteers has managed to collect
basically a full chess set
just from cleaning the beaches because
anything you've ever made a plastic if
we don't currently have a solution on
how to recycle plastic it's going to end
up somewhere best-case scenario right
now is that ends up in landfill but we
do know that these chemicals are
leeching out of the landfills
into our water so even if we put these
plastics in landfill it could still end
up the plastic there chemicals could
still end up in the sea it's almost like
we need a complete rethink of not only
our consumption of plastic but is an our
entire consumer society isn't it and
that and that's really where we're at
you you're one of those PhD students
from Oxford University who have joined
the a debris cleanup what have you got
out of it and to be with local say shell
while people as well to come here and
try and make this pristine place more
pristine absolute roller coaster and
life-changing experience these guys are
amazing
I've made friends for life I've also
really struggled with the heat I mean
coming fro it was snowing when we left
Oxford and came here and it's sometimes
35 degrees you know very high humidity
working in the hot Sun but I can feel
like that's sort of how it should be to
get the privilege of coming here when
you're not so sure was the dream for a
shalwar people to come here most can't
so if you are British to be able to come
here should have a good reason to come
here and it should be hard and it's and
it's really bad that's so hard to get
this plastic off
Jesse Mahoney Thank You Craig Franco you
were born in the UK but you are say
Cheryl I lived there now amazing trip
for you as well to try to restore and I
know as Tracy was saying people in the
seychelles dream dream dream of coming
to a Dubrow don't they absolutely this
is like winning the lottery for anyone
from the Seychelles so yeah coming here
is a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity very
privileged to be here and I think for us
as well it's amazing to be a part of the
solution as well somewhere as pristine
as this place should be
it's it's despairing to see it like this
but it's great to be a part of the
solution particularly as a as a session
as well this is on this Beach and
another very small beach up here and
have to say this is really the whole of
this coastline the northern coastline is
made up of coral ancient coral isn't it
so there's only a couple of beaches so
this is what you found just in small
small areas it's worth remembering so
this is something that we've done in
less than an hour small group of us and
this is a drop in the ocean compared to
what we've been doing down in the South
but we've got flip-flops as you can see
I think we've got two or three bags of
flip-flops in 50 minutes already we've
got some pet bottles here also from all
around the world some branded as well
some have been in the ocean for so long
as well they're starting to degrade and
turn into fragments
we have miscellaneous items consumables
glass bottles as Josie said anything and
everything that you can imagine we're
finding here amazing stuff just one
quick thought as well we've got dr.
Lindsey Turnbull who is on the board of
the Seychelles Islands and a she knows
also the mastermind behind the other bra
cleanup the reason this is so important
on beaches like this is because of the
holes that we see peppering these
beaches and they are turtle nesting site
green turtle nesting sites so it's
really important they get a clear on
because it's such hard work for them to
lay their eggs
absolutely the females when you see them
hauling themselves up these beaches it's
exhausting for them they can only do a
couple of pulls at a time and they have
to stop and you can hear them these huge
exhalations and then they go again then
when they get there they've got to dig
these enormous holes they have to dig
deep and they have to cover those eggs
carefully because there are a lot of
things here who would love to eat those
eggs and if there are obstructions in
the way then of course anything that
makes it harder for those adult turtles
just adds to their burden and then
there's the hatchlings when they emerge
they have to race to the sea two minutes
or they're not going to make it and
anything that obstructs them any
flip-flops bottles that are in the way
just means they're less likely to get
out there well one person who saw that
with your help was our science
correspondent Thomas Moore who is out
there on the ocean let's just see very
quickly if we can get down
far as the ocean Zephyr the mothership
it's where the nekton mission is basing
their first ascent project which is what
we have joined them with and he's been
working with the scientists to see some
of the micro plastics on the ship as
they bring up things like the sea fans
and some of those coral samples that
Mark was talking about right at the top
of the program Thomas you're on the ship
yes indeed Anna we've seen plenty of sea
fans and sea whips other forms of coral
we haven't yet seen great quantities of
micro plastic it's not directly what
they're looking for at the moment on the
ship that one can expect that micro
plastics are in every sea in every
region of the world and indeed at every
depth as Louise has has found now the
problems that you're seeing on algebra
are just going to get worse and worse
look back to the 1960s and there were 15
million tons of plastic being produced
now it's anywhere north of 320 million
tons and that will double again over the
next 20 years this is something the
world really needs to get to grips with
with 32 percent of all plastic produced
leaks out into the environment carried
down by rivers swept out to sea by the
wind and then ends up in places like
Aldabra
and Louise Olcott and you're one of the
scientists onboard the nekton ship and
you normally study the the Seas of
Ireland but you're seeing the same
problems there yeah we see plastic
everywhere
I mean people use it if it's anywhere on
the ocean margin where people use
plastic it will make its way into the
ocean and from the ocean it makes its
way into deeper water so wherever we
look we will find plastics so what can
you do then we have to start wrestling
it that's that's the only thing we can
do the only way to stop it getting into
the ocean is to stop having it in the
first place and so we've really got to
change our habits you can use paper bags
you can use permanent base you can use
cloth bags just got to stop using
plastic so these are choices we can all
make absolutely I mean you see us on
board or walking around with our water
bottles we've got we've got refillable
bottles we don't need single-use plus
nobody needs single-use plastic bottles
we've just got to change our mindset and
think differently sometimes we are
powerless some players consumers we want
to do the right thing but we're not
given the option yeah so I mean I would
stages right to the company's object
call them out on Twitter
you know use social media platforms if
you if the consumers make enough fuss
companies will change but I was walking
on algebra yesterday I found evidence of
plastic hammering from as far away as
Indonesia there's several thousand miles
across the Indian Ocean clearly people
there have other priorities a much less
developed nation than the UK or there
are other European countries and clearly
they want to make sure they've got food
on the table and all too often companies
are producing items in small pouches and
that makes it very difficult for them
economically to make the choices that
and that we might like them to make yes
and I think this is where where
governments and blow
the UN has a role to play you know we
are a global nation we it's a big world
but there is joined up thinking there is
the UN and these police these places
have to play a role in making sure that
that processes are put in place to
minimize plastic and change the general
way we treat our planet
thank you very much need for now Louisa
I know have you got any evidence from
the plastic that you've seen on your
little beach there that that plastic is
coming from a long way or happen indeed
those labels have been washed off
they've been so long in the water say
and actually they're trying to try and
track some of the waste that circles
around the Indian Ocean Lindsay I know
you've done some research into this
haven't you but where it's come from
that's right so with an oceanographic
colleague in Oxford her name's Helen
Johnson she was trying to do some ocean
current modeling so it's quite
interesting you have these models of
ocean currents and then you can put
particles in you can say here are my
particles they they are on Aldabra you
can then run that model backwards in
time and try to work out where those
things actually came from and originally
we thought that they appeared in the
model to be coming from the coast of
East Africa but I have to say I've found
nothing here with a Kenya or a Tanzania
or a Somali label on and what she
wondered whether in these models with
particles sort of getting trapped at the
coast and have they actually come from
much further afield and I think now
that's quite likely now we've actually
been here and seen that the dominant
label to be honest is Indonesia then
perhaps we are getting things coming
from truly thousands of miles away which
is incredible floats floats on the
currents and here it ends up in the home
of the giant Aldabra tortoises only two
places in the world that these are
endemic one is the Galapagos and the
other is here and this is called but I
want to wake them up this is called
the Galapagos of the Indian Ocean for
this reason or amongst these reasons
there they are they need to get out of
the Sun that they cannot be in it it
would literally cook them so they need
to make sure they take some shade if
they can not a lot of shade here I have
to say and they're sleeping away it's
very interesting seeing them sleeping at
night - they literally seem to expire
they run out of energy and they flop
down legs extended and arms extended
flat on the floor fascinating that these
almost didn't exist here after about
1900 they were nearly wiped out on the
island of our Dabra they'd been
plundered by sailors by
settlers and there they are now this is
of course deep ocean live we're trying
to see the relationship now between the
habitats of this collar atoll made as it
is by coral and the deep out there in
the ocean and the importance of the to
mark Austin of course has been down in
the deep today let's see what he saw
from some pretty remote and amazing
places in my time but none quite so
remote or amazing as this let me just
show you the picture here and it is
quite unnerving in some ways it's like
we descended into it all together to the
alien world which of course we have it's
like a moonscape but the bottom of the
sea at this depth is barely a glimmer of
sunlight what you're seeing are the
lights of the submersible the technical
name for where we are is the rarer
photic zone and if you saw our program
yesterday with Ana well this is a now
about a hundred meters deeper and what's
so exciting about this is that we are
probably the first down here it's
largely unexplored unmapped and
unsurveyed and so in some ways it is a
privilege to be here the job today the
task today is to establish the impact of
man on the ocean a recent study by New
Castle's University scientists suggested
there is more than three hundred and
ninety-three million tons of plastic in
our oceans but only two hundred and
forty six thousand tons is on the
surface that means that 99% our 99.9
percent is suspended in the water around
us it's lying in the bottom it was
buried in the seabed and it's a quite a
frightening a frightening thought Randy
and I mean how much different is this
from where you were yesterday hundred
meter
further out well we've gone a lot deeper
today and the landscape has changed
quite a bit so instead of seeing that
vertical wall we're seeing more of a
slope of hard bedrock and these broken
boulders that that were clinging to
right now
yeah and we're having to cling on
because if the slope is so sharp here
and what about being down here you know
it's very deep as I say it's 250 meters
the pressure is what something like you
know 325 times what we're seeing on the
surface down here yeah and the it's 25
times that's 360 I'm working it out 367
psi and the temperature down here is 12
degrees Celsius where I was at the top
on that ship where I was yesterday it
was you know 34 degrees what kind of
depth from this submersible we're in I'm
getting worried well even though it's
designed so 300 meters they pressure
test it to 25% beyond that and designed
for even deeper so like we say I mean we
can go to any job sometimes yeah but the
pressure on us now I mean if we tried to
it's it's so much that we couldn't open
the hatch if we wanted to in fact I
could undock it and there's no way you
could open that hatch there's so much
force holding it closed 12 degrees down
there we heard from Mark I can't tell
you what it is here it is baking and
this is a robber crab they wreak havoc I
have to say that I did not sleep last
night because this these things lots of
them try to get into my tent literally
tried to unzip it I think at one point
they come they smell they have
extraordinary sense of smell they can
smell the food that we were cooking and
there were hundreds of them on the beach
last night 15 different sorts of land
crabs here thank you Jesse for bringing
that one we're going to get another
orange one in a man I mean I think
fifteen different land crabs on this
island just shows there are so many
different species here that are thriving
because human beings are not and as we
heard earlier this is not a place for
mammals there are some rats some cats
not on
which is one of the four islands of the
Aldabra atoll all surrounding this
Lagoon none on here so no mammals means
other species flightless birds and other
creatures so this is obviously all about
the oceans the protection of the oceans
if you don't protect the ocean you don't
protect places like this at all so let's
bring in our Peter Thompson who is the
UN Special Envoy for the oceans and I
have to say seeing places like this
having been underwater to in the
submersible you realize how much work
there is to do and why all of this needs
protecting so much yes thank you for
having me on the show and
congratulations to you all out there and
Aldabra at all it's just amazing that
you've put this together you know I have
in my lifetime I'm from Fiji seen
pristine atolls and then see them
atrophy over the decades with the the
plague of plastic that we've set upon
the ocean it isn't just plastic of
course is it it is global warming -
certainly the Seychelles is amongst
those places that have been really hit
hard and I know in the 2016 coral mass
bleaching episode that it was very
difficult that the water temperature
that we see behind us that shouldn't
really go above 29 degrees for coral
reached 30 degrees over four consecutive
months sometimes spiking at 31 degrees
so coral bleaching is here on the
granitic Islands a little bit here in
Aldabra - how important is it you think
that the world wakes up to the
difficulty of climate change and what
that is doing to the oceans
it's absolutely existential for us if we
even care a little bit about the
well-being of our children and
grandchildren this is probably the most
important thing facing humanity at the
moment climate change in ocean change so
there's there's no getting away from
that
unfortunately the ocean is in deep
trouble you've pretty succinctly put it
there in distinguishing between climate
change and things like pollution and
fishing I see it as as two area
one is imminently fixable which is the
fishing and the pollution side that is
just man management getting the laws in
place on and doing the business and I
firmly believe we can do that over the
next decade clean up the ocean and
sensibly manage our fish stocks and get
into sustainable aquaculture and all the
rest but there is a much more difficult
challenge that we're facing which is the
climate change challenge and that is
where we have to address our GHG
emissions with what we're putting into
the atmosphere because that is what's
really damaging oceans health you know
you're looking at things like ocean
acidification deoxygenation ocean
warming and as you say the effects of
all that such as you know coral die-off
and rising sea levels yes and in fact
I'm walking as you're talking towards
the ocean Zephyr which is the mothership
for the scientists of the natural
mission who we've joined with and
certainly when I've been down in the
submersibles we've been taking some of
those readings that you mentioned there
the salinity readings the acidity
readings and it's really important isn't
it to say to people that actually the
extra carbon dioxide we're putting into
the atmosphere is being absorbed in
there and it can't keep doing it already
we heard from the principal scientist
she saw in the Antarctica evidence of
shells melting because of acid the acid
in the water the carbonic acid in the
water so really change is already
happening isn't it absolutely right and
you know there's the the continuing and
acidification of the ocean is purely
related to the co2 levels in the
atmosphere so yeah that that is going to
make life things very difficult life in
the ocean you know you think of any
calcium carbonate based life form like
shellfish or vertebrates
you know how are they going to form
their skeletons if they're being if this
rising acidification is being applied to
them so that's that but the the ocean
warming side is so tragic andand that's
just obviously it's the atmosphere warms
with our greenhouse gas emissions the
ocean warms as well because the ocean
takes
most of that ocean of our warmth that
we're producing is absorbed in the ocean
so in the past we've thought the oceans
big enough to take it but now we realize
it's not and we're seeing the effects
for one thing sea level rise in our age
- expands only one way to go up which is
now only one way to go which is up you
know think of the ocean as a bathtub
there's only one ocean so as you expand
up go the levels and think of the not
just the Pacific Islands of atolls like
elder brother which will go underwater
but think of those coastal areas like
Bangladesh you know river deltas which
support tens of millions of people all
going underwater where are people going
to go so you've also got with ocean
warming the tragedy of coral reefs the
the thought that by the end of the this
century we could be in a position where
there are no longer any coral reefs for
me coming from Fiji brought up on a
coral coast this is tragic beyond belief
and it's a kinder saying there'll be no
more forests on land the coral reefs are
the bunkers of biodiversity for the
oceans and to take them out of the
picture you know it could well be the
taking out of the the ocean ecosystem
and therefore they're taking out of our
global ecosystem and therefore us yes
and indeed people say don't they that
they are less than 1% of the landmass
but 25% of the diversity while you're
talking we're right by ancient coral
here it's about 125,000 years old
probably lifted up as sea levels drop at
some time in its history there are whole
corals here actually some mushroom coral
here a flat one but it does shows you
that this is what the living form of
this is what needs to be protected now
to keep the diversity that you're
talking about and certainly some of
those governments that you mentioned did
head to the g7 to try and make their
case governments like that here in the
Seychelles or the Maldives to make the
point you're making
you must feel as UN Special Envoy that
you want to bang heads against a wall
about this you must be so frustrated
about it
yeah well I I'm in a different country
every week talking to governments and
conferences about the urgency of the
situation the predicament that humanity
is in but the fact that we have a plan
where and the plan of course is the
Paris climate agreement and the
sustainable development goals in the
case of the oceans SDG 14 so we have to
be faithful to the implementation of
that plan and you know as you know there
are some that are sort of in denial and
that just means that those of us that
know the truth have to carry a heavier
burden and push all harder and when I
say no the truth we get the truth from
the very best of our scientists who've
been assembled in the IPCC and put out
reports from time to time and these
scientists are not people from another
planet you know that they're getting
their information from the weather
offices of every country on the globe
and they collect those daily at the
World Meteorological Organization in
Geneva and this is the truth you know
there's no avoiding the truth so the
rest is obfuscation the truth is there
well it's been great to have you honored
to hear your perspective and the hard
work that you are doing thank you very
much indeed there Peter Thompson un
special envoy to the oceans who's
clearly trying to get the message across
we will be back on the ocean zephyr our
mothership later on today hopefully back
down in the deep tomorrow it's clearly a
very difficult project this is I have to
say the first time that anybody has been
live on algebra at all it is a week of
firsts here at Sky News and I just want
to say a big thank you to everybody
who's trying to take shelter from just
post the midday Sun to Lindsay as well
you've been great to have on all the way
through thank you so much and for your
team as well it's been great to have you
here and presumably one message we're
watching at home about what to do about
plastic about climate change and about
the relationship to places like this I
think don't give up hope it's very easy
to think this problem is so enormous so
difficult that simply can't be solved
and he should sit on your sofa and eat a
big bag of crisps instead but that's not
the right response we have to do things
we have to team up we have to work
together we have to this is these are
global problems we can do it and we have
to believe in ourselves and we have to
just do it
okay thank you very much indeed dr.
Lindsay temple thanks very much indeed
so from all of us here on Aldabra after
at all it has been a quite extraordinary
experience I have to say thank you
indeed for watching back with deep ocean
live tomorrow
[Music]